other developing a Polish historiography
is the beginning of the rethinking of
the Commonwealth which initially is
frequently called Poland not the
Commonwealth of two peoples and to
emphasize that it was the Commonwealth
of at least two nations and later of
many nations you can look at professor
Kaminski's book with this this topic but
I think a professor get off ski
rewriting and saying he'd been opened up
to these topics that he had developed
from an N deck family tradition away
from that tradition and in his vision of
the past he began to think in these ways
the other elements of Polish
historiography were there were a few
topics that were taboo or be
ideologically regulated in the 60s 70s
and 80s but Ukrainian topics were one
such topic and there are two reasons for
it one the contemporary antagonism
between poles and Ukrainians made
certain blinders by Polish historians
who were otherwise otherwise good
historians say these were topics even
when they projected into the past and
secondly there were constraints from a
government and ideological ideological
mandates that's the reason why professor
Boyd chicks books on G keepo Yvonne oh
the wild filled in fire in the 1960s
this popular book on the cause ox
relations of the Commonwealth with the
cause ops was such an important
breakthrough on a popular level that
mean it went through three editions it
becomes bestseller we can only dream of
today because the Polish intelligent
public wanted it but as well because it
was a breakthrough on ukrainian topics
but i can give you a case of what kind
of what existed in poland scholarship
was relatively free but in the early
1970s i had to carry out a manuscript
from poland on heffman petrol doroshenko
and the commonwealth a 17th century
topic because professor peradeniya was
had been told that his book could never
be published in poland and even though
he had gone to give nauseam with one of
the high communist officials and his
wife had appealed to to him the answer
was there are certain topics that
shouldn't be written about well to have
a topic in Polish in Poland at that time
where you couldn't write about it
on pseudo polish topics of the 17th
century was unheard of socho that
ukrainian topics still had a different a
different connotation and then i think
of the the rather unpleasant debate in
chevron dist history HD / torres akin
chefs Cahill's book in the 1980s this
was about a book about national
consciousness of the ukrainian nobility
and cause acts of the sixteenth and
seventeenth century and it is not the
issue of the merits there's much
discussion of details of manuscripts and
other such things that are worthy of
discussion but it was the virulence of
the attack on the book and the fact that
a very reputable polish journal did not
have editors who would turn to these
rather young scholars would say don't do
it now it was interesting in this cases
in chaska handle for those of you know
that her name hello by family relation
comes from the two god Nick polchak knee
the Catholic inteligencia group of
Poland and the attack came by someone a
young scholar who was a communist party
member which was at that point fairly
rare of young scholars in history so
became an idea ideological fight as well
now in contrast ukrainian historiography
survived by a number of fortuitous
circumstances first of all that
Professor kripya kovitch did not get out
in time in 1944 and so he remained
behind interview later persecuted
eventually brought back into the
scholarly world and he had great impact
on another generation of scholars and
that in the city of the other developed
to counter polling forces both dealing
with this period one of Professor is
saya veciana /si average who rides
wonderful things on culture and the
Brotherhood's when the shortfall occurs
in the late 1960s and 70s and the other
professor dosh kovitch who when he comes
back from prison camp gets involved in
writing on the armenians a video in this
period and gets support from the
Armenians he is the opposition is total
visiting historian SI images becomes
part of the establishment but they are
two European scholars on the general
European level working in this city and
they in many ways I think are
responsible that there is some
continuity of historical
mission in the city of ko Kiev where the
the purge is much greater of historians
there are a few people like shevchenko
feather Pavlovich butit's who puts out
the documents and they maintain some
condition at least level of learning on
this period and then the strange quirk
of the city of Newport Petrovsky deeper
Petrovsky University then known as near
Petros University in the name of the
300th anniversary of the reunification
of Ukraine with Russia I think that's
the longest title of university I know
no longer was directly under Moscow
University